[music playing]
NARRATOR: In the
desert of Gebelein,
just south of Luxor,
Meredith searches
for evidence of Egypt's
earliest death rites.
She believes the myths that
drove Egyptians to mummify
their own bodies had
roots much earlier than
ancient Egyptian civilization.
Prehistoric rock art
depicting wildlife
suggests this area was
once a sacred place.
In the 19th century,
archeologists identified it
as a burial ground.
This is a desolate
dry landscape.
Nothing much to
see on the surface.
But underneath these
rocks and sand,
there would have been
prehistoric tombs.
NARRATOR: In 1896,
an Egyptologist
from the British
Museum received a tip
off of a momentous discovery.
Buried under a thin
layer of desert debris,
local farmers had found a
mummified body preserved
in astonishing detail.
On the upper arm,
tattoos of horned animals
were still visible.
And from the head sprouted
tufts of red hair,
earning this mummy its
original nickname, ginger.
There was a puncture wound
to the left shoulder blade
and a fractured rib beneath.
Forensic analysis has
revealed the body is
male and over 5,000 years old.
But how is this body
so perfectly preserved?
For Meredith, the evidence
suggests the man's
mummification was not planned.
Instead, it was an
accident of nature.
In this photo,
I can see there's
no bandages or
anything that would
have preserved this mummy.
So it would seem
that this was not
an intentional mummification.
He was preserved by the sand.
There was no ritual or magic
or anything involved, just
the drying power of nature.
NARRATOR: Hundreds of years
before the first pharaoh,
this man lived around
the fertile flood
plains along the River Nile.
But around his 20th birthday,
he was brutally stabbed
in the back and left for dead.
He was buried in a shallow grave
with simple clay grave goods
and covered with sand.
But the desert sun
and hot dry sand
quickly evaporated all
the water from his body,
stopping it from
decomposing, freezing
him in time until his
discovery 5,400 years later.
Archeologists have found
no papyri that explained
the historical origins
of mummification,
but Meredith believes the
practice could have evolved
from accidents of nature.
Natural mummies
like the Gebelein man
would have inspired
ancient Egyptians.
That if they could
use technology
to harness the power of
nature, their bodies too could
last forever into eternity.
It's a truly
spectacular discovery.
It tells us where
mummification started.
[music playing]